foreign
to share a truth with you
and so I am ready to share my truth and
the truth is I love scam artists
I mean I don't love scam artists I love
learning about them I love reading books
about them watching documentaries about
them I love learning about the tele
shopping queen bana Marquis in Italy I
like learning how to avoid creeps like
Simon levied you know the Tinder
swindler
I even liked watching both fire Festival
documentaries the day they came out and
have listened to every single radio edit
of every Billy McFarland interview that
exists in this Dimension I'm like
obsessed and I think we can all learn a
lot from scam artists you know not like
how to live your life or something
but specifically how money functions in
our society so if you're ready to go on
this journey with me today I would like
to teach you money lessons from famous
scam artists yeah yeah yeah
so how did I get here well I'm an artist
you know minus the scam part I'm a poet
and a filmmaker specifically and when I
started my Arts Journey full time over a
decade ago I was unprepared for the
amount of Grants I'd have to write turns
out that a lot of being a professional
artist is fundraising for your own
salary
so I got good at Grants I got so good at
Grants I started writing grants for
other people and one year alone through
writing grants for folks running
people's fundraising campaigns
supporting Mutual Aid efforts I was able
to help move 1.3 million dollars
directly into the hands of black Trans
individuals and organizations
thank you
I started Consulting with philanthropic
organizations on the best way to support
targeted communities and I teach
reparations Frameworks all across the
country so I know why people give money
and honestly a lot of it is great
storytelling and scam artists are really
good at spinning a narrative
now the first famous scam artist I'd
like to tell you all about is the
infamous Elizabeth Holmes so Elizabeth
Holmes who founded therinos was able to
rake in about a nine billion dollar
valuation for a product that didn't even
work
for those of you that don't remember
Elizabeth Holmes because you somehow I
don't know like missed the competing
podcast the book the documentary and the
very public trial let me remind you who
she is so she started theranos onto the
premise that they would be creating a
device that could read hundreds of
medical uh tests through a single drop
of blood
now she surrounded herself with
government officials uh Venture
capitalists and a bevy of high gloss
magazine covers what she did not
surround herself with though were
medical experts as peers right and so
for many people and for many of them
that that came close to her they could
realize pretty quickly that what she was
selling just wasn't real and so for most
folks it's very clear that Elizabeth
Holmes is a scammer but have you ever
listened to the rationalizations of her
funders that stuff is gold
so out of all of her investors my
favorite interview is one with Don Lucas
senior so don Lucas senior who gave her
millions of dollars was asked to explain
why did you give her so much money and
so he said well her great grandfather
was an entrepreneur and it turns out the
hospital near where her family lives is
named for her great uncle yeah so she
was supposedly The Best of Both Worlds
and had supposedly learned both medicine
and Entrepreneurship through osmosis
another Gem of an interview was with Tim
Draper so Tim Draper pushed back against
an interviewer who asked now do you
think that Elizabeth Holmes being a
family friend of yours had anything to
do with you giving her so much money he
scoffed I mean he's a professional he
doesn't do trivial things like that he
was the first investor in Tesla and
Skype he just knows who's going to go
the distance
and as we know there are no stanked
horribly and publicly after opening 40
centers at arizona-based Walgreens
locations and endangering thousands of
people who got blood tests that the
company knew were going to be faulty
a lie we get told again and again is
that broke folks are bad at money
It's Working Class folks who make bad
decisions about money this brings us to
our first lesson people with wealth
aren't better at making decisions they
get to make more bad decisions without
it hurting them
with the added bonus of being able to
cause extensive harm to the people over
whom they will to power
when broke folks make bad decisions
about money
it only impacts them
not whole ecosystems
okay the next famous scamworks I'd like
to talk to you all about is the story of
Margaret and Walter King now in the
1960s Walter got famous for painting but
guess what Walter doesn't do Walter
doesn't paint okay he steals all of the
work from Margaret right and these
beautiful pieces known for the resonant
features of children with big eyes were
showing off at clubs at festivals even
at the U.N they made him millions of
dollars he even had celebrity clientele
such as the Kennedy family
because of the difficulty of being taken
seriously as an artist who was a woman
it was easy to erase Margaret from her
work Walter even was able to convince
her that this was the best way to get
her work seen at all which brings us to
our next point and lesson for the day
in an unjust Society our social
identities are often used as markers to
decide whether we are worthy of being
taken seriously or deserving of
Financial and other resources okay and
when I'm saying other resources I'm
saying sometimes it's money sometimes
it's food sometimes it's housing
sometimes it's water
the next story that's coming up to me
actually is not a scam artist story per
se but a triumph over a scam artist
story if I can if I can diverge just for
a little bit is that okay yeah and so
I'm thinking so much about the story of
Carlette Duffy so carlett Duffy is a
black woman based in Indianapolis and in
2020 she decided that she needed to
refinance her home and so when she did
that she had two appraisal teams come
down and they both undervalued her home
extensively the lowest appraisal being
at a hundred and ten thousand dollars so
she had an idea she took down every
picture of her family from her home she
removed every single piece of artwork
that depicted black people she removed
all of her hair products and she called
a friend a white man that news Outlet
simply referred to as Hank well don't
you know that when Hank stood in for her
at the next appraisal her home went from
being worth a hundred and ten thousand
dollars to two hundred and fifty nine
thousand dollars
does that sound like a scam to you
because it sounds like a scam to me
and in that story what I think also
comes up is how common that scam is and
it is one that's based in redlining
practices and white supremacy culture
now the next and last scam artist that I
would like to share with y'all is the
amazing Anna Sorkin aka Anna Del V okay
yeah so some of y'all are fans I could
tell okay hide your wallets okay and so
uh
so annadelby pretended to be a German
heiress and she almost every space she
went into she took the New York scene of
financial institutions and socialites
for a ride that would cost them
275 thousand dollars she lived in
sprawling Apartments she flew on private
chats uh she uh vacationed on Yachts she
ate meals that cost as much as my rent
she said she was rich
she looked the part and so as a result
people felt compelled to give her more
money think of how ridiculous that
sounds because she said she was rich she
looked apart people thought she also
needed their money whether a gift or a
loan Anna would always promise to pay
people back that decided they wanted to
help her and supposedly urgent
situations when she wasn't able to
access her totally fictional but
supposedly sprawling Fortune
Wadena story reminds me is this next
point
again an unjust system and an unjust
Society those who are seen as being able
to perform wealth are more likely to get
funded than those in actual Financial
need not only is this a gross practice
it's an unsustainable one in 2014 a
study found that over consumption and
economic inequality leads to the
collapse of civilizations
while having a lot of wealth may be able
to buy you a PR team to make you more
likable to the general population
it doesn't make you a more skilled
person it doesn't make you more capable
and it certainly doesn't make you more
perceptive about the sustainability of
resources this idea that wealthy people
are somehow more deserving is one that
is very pervasive and one that many
different types of people believe in
this Society because of all the systems
we live under lots of broke folks also
believe the idea that they are somehow
less worthy than their wealthy
counterparts
scam artists
actually know something that most of us
in this room would deny or refuse to
accept and that is
money doesn't typically come from hard
work
money comes to those who hoard it money
comes to those who are willing to
exploit money comes to those who work
hard to bury the history of where money
comes from billions of people live on
this planet that work hard every single
day that will live and die broke
money comes to financial institutions
like Bank of America and JPMorgan Chase
who literally got their start in the
transatlantic slave trade and will find
themselves in the news every few years
for denying loans to the very
descendants of the same people they once
owned
two uh big Tech giants like apple and
Amazon who will pay top dollar for a
coder behind a desk in Seattle but will
pay darn near nothing for the hands of
those that work tirelessly to mine the
materials that make our devices function
and to deliver our packages cheaply to
living in a society where it is legal to
pay both disabled workers and essential
workers less than minimum wage the way
we deal with money in this Society is
the real scam
and while the scam artists that I'm
talking about have had their tricks and
tools exposed for the whole world to see
there are scams in our faces every
single day
so what do I want you to get out of
today
I want you to consider that there are
scams that we are asked to agree not to
see all the time
and I want you to think about in your
personal life in your interpersonal life
and in your Greater Community Life what
are some scams that we are asked to
pretend are okay and understanding that
when we do that we set up a lot of our
communities to fail
as an artist I had the distinct pleasure
and joy of helping people to dream
possibilities that don't already exist
on this planet
so today I'm asking you to dream with me
I want you to dream a possible world
in which we delegate resources like
money from a place of community care
what do actual ethical practices around
money look like
money in this Society
is often used to prove morality
competency wisdom when really it's just
a tool we made up
and we get to decide how we use it how
we move forward with it or without it
for the collective good
thank you
yeah
[Applause]